We welcome to the stage director,
auto Bathurst and stars,
Ben Mendelsohn,
Sarah and Hagar 10 and Jay,
fuck
yeah,
I'm taking a selfie.
How are you doing?
No,
was it here?
You Rolling?
I am rolling.
In case you didn't tell for Pinto,
so dead on your pants to grant.
Okay.
Uh,
I actually want to start with auto.
the movie.
This movie is actually getting released on the 21st of November here and it's
going to be a released 110 years after the first Robin Hood was ever made,
which was nice.
You know,
eight obviously.
Um,
there've been many,
many different remakes,
many different iterations of this.
Uh,
what made you decide to do a another one eight years now after the last remake?
It's a good question.
Um,
and I'll tell you when I was,
when they came to me and said,
do you want to make another Robert Film?
I,
the initial reaction was like,
really?
Do we really need another Robinhood film?
That'd been plenty of them.
And then I kind of sort of dug into it and realize that actually the,
the versions that we all know,
whether it be from Hollywood or from the British film industry,
and that is a very,
very,
very narrow view of the kind of Robin Hood Story.
This is a story that's lasted for like six,
700 years and has been told him so many iterations.
And you,
as you asked the question,
you ask yourself why,
why,
why is this story lasted for so long?
You know,
and I guess,
you know,
wherever you've got corruption,
wherever you've got,
you know,
any kind of political organization or king or queen oppressing the people.
Whenever you've got a religion,
you know,
oppressing the people,
then you think we need a Robin hood story,
forward wines.
The 21st century we got,
you know,
why not two political leaders who are a little abusing their power.
We've got,
um,
some religions oppressing people in one or two countries in the world.
We've got the occasional unjust war being fought,
you know,
in some countries.
And you kind of go,
you know,
now more than ever do we need,
a Robin Hood Story.
So then you kind of go,
okay,
but how do we do it?
And you know,
I wanted to make,
and we didn't want to make a sort of a little history lesson or dusty British
fairy tale.
If this is going to be for the 21st century,
we've got to make a version of it that kind of relates to the 21st century
audience.
And so we jazzed it up a bit.
You did.
It's a very different,
I saw it last week.
Um,
and it,
it's,
it's darker.
It's actually a bit darker I think.
What do you mean by that?
Solid is racial tension up here,
man.
You did look right at me.
It's a bit darker Jamie and I'll just get,
mmm.
I felt good.
Felt like Dave Chappelle.
There's a knife.
So Pam,
Pam,
I was beside myself.
I'm just letting you go,
man.
Do your thing.
Yeah.
Okay.
Uh,
yeah.
So the screenplay and the screenplay is a bit darker.
Did you purposely want to take it in a different direction?
The screenplay.
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
Listen,
I mean,
yeah,
there's no,
there's no point.
If anybody wants to see a traditional Robin hood with men and green tights,
don't go and see this film.
You'll be very disappointed.
This is a very,
very,
very different take on the whole thing.
And uh,
Jamie,
you're obviously a bit of a comedian
started out and I can't see you over there.
You can leave a chair up.
Oh yeah.
A started out in living color when you were always attracted to comedy.
Uh,
you know,
I've always been like,
uh,
growing up,
you know,
as,
as a kid,
you know,
doing,
I used to do standup comedy and my third grade class,
they would give us like,
time.
My teacher was like,
either you're going to,
you're going to end up being in the office every day or I'm going to set aside
some time for you every Friday and just let you tell jokes to the kids.
And so luckily I had a teacher that was looking at,
and then I would take,
you guys are too young to notice,
but Johnny Carson,
hilarious.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Oh wait,
hey Johnny,
Johnny Carson,
the original tonight show.
I would just take jokes from the tonight show and tell them to the kids.
Uh,
you know,
they thought I was a brilliant comedian when I was actually stealing from Johnny
Carson and a,
and that's how I,
that's how I started out,
you know,
and then,
uh,
got to,
got to La and I'm just started doing all of the clubs and a am I suppose to be
saying this.
Yeah.
Go on
in a,
in,
in got to La and started doing standup in the clubs.
And I remember the first time I went on stage in La and it was a lot of gang
members in the,
in the crowd at that time because La was sort of like,
you know,
I didn't know what bloods and crips,
what was,
it was a lot of crips in the audience at that time.
And so they were yelling and throwing stuff at people and stuff who was on
stage.
And then I just went up,
started doing impersonations,
but I would do them as if I was the crip.
So I would do like Mike Tyson and yet my tie him [inaudible] and so,
and at that time I was the only black guy doing a Ronald Reagan at the time,
so,
well,
well as a matter of fact,
Bill,
there you go again.
And so they sort of jumped off from there and I got on to live in color and the
rest was a rest was history
and you often very musically musically talented got the Oscar for uh,
for Ray Ray Charles,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
how,
what made you want to do the transition I guess from,
uh,
from comedy to serious?
I couldn't get a spot.
Like you got to think about,
well,
we was coming up all of the lands.
It was a like a thousand of them
and then it was,
you know what I'm saying?
It was Martin Lawrence,
it was Chris Rock.
It was all of those guys that were doing like,
I mean it was crowded.
So every time I tried to jump off,
like especially in movies,
like to try to do something funny,
there was nothing out there,
you know,
because all of the sort of the slots was taken up.
And then along came a little,
oh,
this,
this movie called any given Sunday,
which was um,
uh,
Oliver stone.
And that sort of changed the trajectory of,
of,
you know,
what,
what I was to be.
And then once we caught that lit,
you know,
we always trying to catch the live.
So I caught that.
I was like,
okay,
now I can step into that space.
And then those types of dramatic roles,
uh,
continuing to,
to come along willy,
well when I released my name is Willie Willie Beeman.
Yeah,
Dan.
So that's,
you know,
that's how I,
that's how I jumped off.
Right.
And you had obviously a lot of musical background as well,
but Taryn,
you,
you can sing really well by the way,
in case you didn't know,
um,
you are actually Johnny from thing is my son's favorite character.
So really cool.
Thank you.
Where,
where did your history come from?
Cause you,
you have a,
your Welsh,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I,
um,
I grew up in Wales and there's a very strong tradition of choral scene.
Hello.
I can't hear you.
Um,
uh,
so yes,
I grew up in kind of choir singing and my dad's Fetty musical.
I've just always sang of it was left at time.
I don't sing is when I'm not,
when I'm not happy,
you know,
it's,
it's just,
I,
um,
I enjoy it very much.
Are you happy now?
Very happy now,
but I mean I'm mostly trying to do my job now.
Me Too.
This is kind of off topic.
Um,
[inaudible] did you move to there?
One plant?
How do you say how you say that?
Like 20,
20 letters,
20 letters and three vowels
somewhat weak.
Uh,
you say a lot better and I did.
Oh yeah.
So you can turn it,
the Royal Academy of Dramatic Art.
What made you want to start acting in the first?
Um,
I think I,
um,
I've always like storytelling and I've always been a reader.
Um,
autos are actually,
um,
you know,
we were just discussing also his next project,
which is very,
very exciting.
I probably shouldn't say anything.
Should I am allowed to yell?
Just directing some of the news doc materials thing for Hbo,
which is just the Mo,
the coolest thing I've ever,
ever read.
If you haven't read those books,
you must anyway,
boring digression Taryn back on topic.
Robin Hood Promotional 21st Amendment.
Um,
um,
but we were waiting on that.
We waiting on you to sing number.
Are we waiting on him to sing something?
He does this all the time.
Hey t
woke up sick this small noon,
but she was saw mill on sodomy.
I they can't capture
the way you
will not get that seat.
So she wrote sex.
She will.
Anyway,
that's plenty of that.
Come on now.
97.
I said new the adjutant.
I'm just kidding.
Okay,
thank you.
Um,
yes.
Anyway.
Uh,
so,
um,
I was like reading,
storytelling and I think acting was just a natural progression from that really,
which started in my mid teens and audition for drama school and got a place at a
rather,
which was kind of,
you know,
the dream place for me to go and did three years there and then left and then
got Kingsman and now I'm rubbing her.
Did she just really cool?
I'm very lucky guy.
Yeah.
Kingspan was phenomenal.
And of course I'd mentioned saying when,
where did you,
when did you factor thinking into your thing?
Thanks.
I really wanted to do an animated film and I told my agents I was desperate to
do an animated film and then one came along,
which involved going along and singing for the audition.
They said,
do you want to go on best singing gorilla?
And I was like,
are you kidding?
Yes.
Um,
and um,
and then,
then,
you know,
that movie happened and it just became this monstrous SAS,
and,
um,
yeah,
yeah.
We,
I don't think it's the last few seen if Johnny either,
which is really exciting.
Yeah,
yeah.
Spoiler alert.
Hmm.
Um,
Ben,
Ben Mendelsohn.
You're actually Australian.
Yeah.
Okay.
To right.
Um,
you,
I was reading that you took drama because you thought it was an easy class.
Yeah.
All right.
And,
uh,
so how did you make it from Australian TV,
Australian productions over to,
uh,
to the American television?
Uh,
uh,
um,
oh no.
You know how long time I was a,
you know,
I know I started out at about 14.
Uh,
I did a film called animal kingdom,
which kind of,
you know,
blew up a little bit.
And then,
uh,
then what happened?
I got an,
you know,
and then I came over here,
I did a bit of this and did a bit of that.
And then,
you know,
the blood line thing and I did about the line,
did a bit of that and you know,
you could just go,
here I am
show.
Yeah.
We had,
uh,
we had a,
you know,
a game yesterday.
We were on another network,
um,
where we had to do,
you know,
how would you know,
you cast members,
so that's why he's got,
oh,
I forgot the anymore.
It's been,
so it's an uninteresting and saying it doesn't matter.
Yeah.
Go on man.
Yeah,
some one line,
dark light,
dark knight rises,
Star Wars,
rogue one now sheriff and Dottie hand.
I mean you play kind of jerks
and,
but like in my limited time knowing you,
you seem like a really nice guy.
He's,
he's lovely.
So how,
how do you,
how do you find these characters?
Cash,
cash moves everything around me.
Cream.
Get the money.
Don't look,
I labelle's y'all.
So then how did each of the three of you guys get attached to a,
to this project,
to Robin Hood
through,
through auto,
you know,
auto look,
auto auto came and he came with a really strong,
he had a foreign,
he's belly about these because you know,
he's the starting point that he was mentioning earlier.
I'm just,
you know,
assuming that it was something similar for the other gentleman,
but um,
you know,
I came here.
Yeah.
But he said,
look,
you know,
why do a Robin Hood?
Well,
this is why.
And you know,
he transmitted,
he's directing fire to our little act d receptors.
Boom.
We're off.
It's like scale it tricks,
you know what I mean?
You'd drop it down,
you don't have the power on it and like nothing happens.
But you know,
you get zapped and then fuel off.
You got Bush
know you want to and so badly
he can't tell the story of how it really,
you're going to tell.
Oh,
can you tell a story?
You had to postpone production.
We did.
Yeah.
We waited.
The Veneer La.
It's a lot going on with this cast.
And
so how,
I guess I want you to expand on that.
Um,
the,
he wants you to say nice things about,
I'll say nothing about the best Robin Hood.
You,
you,
you found,
yeah.
Yeah.
Always make it.
I mean,
you listen,
we did wait for them cause we would absolutely passionate to have him
Kingsman two at the time.
Yeah.
And he's,
you know,
and he's absolutely perfect for the role.
And when you see the movie,
you'll get why we waited,
you know,
but it's not it as Taran says it,
it does happen.
It does happen quite a lot.
You know,
films,
slide and date slide and other films they're on,
you know,
to go longer or sometimes it will,
sometimes it works the other way.
Sometimes you think you're,
you know,
you think you started in six months and then suddenly or window comes open and
you've got to get going in four weeks.
You know,
so it's,
it's not that unusual,
but that said,
we were very,
very,
very deeply committed to him.
Pain Robin cause awesome.
Thank you.
Yeah,
it was amazing.
And uh,
I mean all of you have such original takes on these characters that we've,
we've seen time and time again,
especially,
uh,
you know,
little John,
uh,
Jamie,
how did you approach this brand new,
the brand new take on that character?
Well,
that,
that's the reason we jumped into it because,
you know,
can I say what the original title was?
The original title of this was called Hood.
So very,
it's a darker tape,
if you will.
But the reason we wanted to fuck with it is because it was like he came with a
brand new bag of funk on how to do it.
Bringing in,
you know,
young terror in that it's not connected to anything traditional.
And what tripped me out was,
I guess I didn't realize that there were a lot of Robin hood movies out there.
I just thought that we was literally like maybe one or two or whatever like
that,
but the fact that he wanted to do it completely different and then do it in a
way to where nothing was,
nothing was attached to the old days.
Even the way it looks,
you know,
a lot of times people will sort of married to whatever the old school look was.
But I thought the,
the,
the clothes in this,
the uh,
what do you call it?
The wardrobe in this is so fly.
I was like,
they should do like a catwalk of the clause because it was so dope.
And so that was the reason that I wanted to jump into it and didn't do my
character in a way to where,
um,
I pattern my character off of,
I don't know how much you know about a cinema,
but,
uh,
when Denzel did Malcolm X,
anybody see that movie?
Uh,
but when Denzel did Malcolm X,
I sorta patterned,
um,
my character,
the guy,
not Denzel.
All right.
Okay.
Uh,
but,
but the guy who went Denzel went to jail.
Yeah.
That got bad guy.
So I was like,
you know,
I mean it was I think back Bertha,
Malcolm.
Yeah.
Oh,
those days.
Oh look at you putting that pocket your hair.
So I was always sorta like channel him.
And so it was just a brand new bag of fun,
you know,
have been where you,
uh,
any similar sort of thing in terms of
no,
but I,
but I love that.
I love that because I actually have a theory that,
you know,
like,
and it's not,
it's not my fucking theory.
It's,
it's just,
you know,
it's well established,
like good artists borrow,
great artists steal.
And that's a genius steel.
That's it to be.
I wouldn't say it is actually true because there's difference,
especially when it comes to movie act and there's little things that you have to
sort of grab,
you know what I mean?
Cause there's some people that great whispers like,
no,
like,
like say like Alec Baldwin.
It was a great whisper.
It tasted great with what's going on.
Of course,
you know,
so,
so it's a movie thing.
So I grabbed that movie thing to Sorta sorta channel that
stealing,
I guess you were saying stole that.
So you're not just to see,
and I know where you're going with this.
So I think I'll jump in and you know,
I'll feed a little bit.
This is why they cast me as villains,
you know,
um,
uh,
cause they'll do whatever the brewer I want.
Um,
he was really about political speak,
like this sheriff,
he's really,
you know,
nodding him is a kind of state.
It's at war.
We need people to be good,
good citizens.
We need a lot of cash and we need you to go off to war and fight.
And if you can't do that,
then you know,
you can make some cash or you can make some weapons.
And if you can't do that,
no,
you know,
Oh,
if you go,
um,
so yeah,
that was more of the vibe and an auto really laid that out.
And there's a plethora of,
um,
you know,
modern political speak are modern examples of that.
That was what you're going to earn us.
Right?
Totally.
100%.
Pushka Karen,
I guess say for you,
did you,
did you watch any of the other previous iterations of Robin Hood or did you just
go out there?
No,
I mean,
you know,
it's,
uh,
you know,
we're all here to facilitate autos,
vision for it,
and also doesn't give a flying Koffler about historical accuracy.
It's just not what floats his boat.
And that's part of what our movie is.
It's a reinvention.
And I,
you know,
I,
I didn't,
I wasn't really interested in watching other Robin Hood's.
I think what I was interested in doing was trying to make a Robin Hood that was,
uh,
you know,
the whole thing is very rock and roll and gritty and fun,
but I wanted him to be a three dimensional and,
um,
and vulnerable.
You know,
he's a young guy,
you know,
he's very sort of boyish in a lot of ways,
which is obviously a huge stretch for me as an actor.
Um,
I,
you know,
I'm,
I,
um,
I just,
wanted him to be fluid and um,
and,
and to not to sort of not really be coping.
I think that's what's interesting about him is he spends a long time not coping
and then becomes later on,
spoiler alert.
Something that we recognize as more heroic.
Alright.
Robin Hood Light.
Yeah.
Um,
there are just there Mike over there.
I know there's a Mike over here.
If you have any questions for anybody,
please start lining up and we'd take probably have time for one or two
questions.
But,
uh,
you said historical accuracy is not what auto cares about.
However,
I'm going to talk about Lars Anderson for a second.
You all right?
They're
getting the water.
Um,
yeah.
Lars Anderson of Denmark who has been nicknamed the real life leg a loss.
Uh,
Ooh,
that's harsh.
That's what he's way better than or loss
taught.
Taught you speed shooting.
If you guys like go look this up on Youtube,
this amazing you want to
talk about Laura's for a second
is,
um,
uh,
a gentleman from Denmark who is a,
um,
uh,
proponents,
is that the right word?
He's,
he,
he basically,
he is a awesome,
why would this particular proponents at this very specific,
uh,
archery style where you hold all of your errors in one hand and you're
essentially able to feed the arrows onto the string of your boat very quickly.
He can do I think nine and four seconds,
can he,
he can do upwards of two second.
And he is,
um,
it's,
it's a bit freakish actually.
And I watched the videos and,
and I,
I didn't,
I didn't buy it to be totally honest.
I didn't think it was real.
And then I met him and it is real.
Um,
and it's really quite extraordinary how quick and how accurate he is from a
great distance.
There was a day,
part of the training we did was we would run around and try and shoot each other
with arrows with big foam heads on them.
And,
um,
and I was crying.
I was getting paid to do this.
Shit's amazing.
Uh,
and,
um,
uh,
and there was a day where I remember I,
I hit him and I didn't often hit him.
I hit him probably from probably the length of this room away.
And,
um,
it was the first time I'd hit him.
And as I hit him,
I made the mistake of laughing.
And,
uh,
I think one gofor into that laugh.
He hit me right between the eyes and no life,
right between the eyes.
I didn't even know it had happened until after it happened.
He,
he's extraordinary.
And I,
I mean,
he's got millions and millions of hits on Youtube and in between my eyes.
Um,
but oh yeah.
Here all weeks,
not just Jamie Fox.
You know,
I've got a few of my back pocket.
Anyway,
I spent a lot of time training with him.
And the archery style you see in the movie is what is what he taught me.
Um,
and he's very cinematic and very fast paced and was kind of,
uh,
an inspired move I think on autos parts.
Cause it's,
it's essentially Robin superpower.
That's that.
It's a superhero movie.
And his archery is his super bar.
What we see in the movie you are doing speed shooting.
Yeah.
I mean I think the studio actually released some clips of me training.
No,
I mean,
you know,
one of the things we wanted to do was to,
to make the movie feel kind of very visceral and you're in it.
And,
and so these guys all had to get in there.
And what you see Robin Hood do on screen Taran adjutant does,
I mean was this like a 2030 40 take thing to do all this stuff or would you like
I got this,
this,
this first track.
I forgot I needed a mic.
Um,
I'm not going to pretend that every hour you see in the film is real because
come on,
we're all grown ups now.
You're shooting at Jamie.
Yeah.
But I think that's part why we've released these clips.
Because I did the w I did the work,
you know the clips,
you know,
and I make a very bold claim to to that.
I want it to be known that I did that work because that's how I think it looks
so realistic in the film is the fact that I had that muscle memory and that
strength from having spent eight weeks doing it in advance of shooting.
I mean Laura's is throwing up targets and turns like,
and it's real.
Yeah,
you're hitting it.
That's great.
But let's got a question here.
Hey,
thanks again for coming guys.
Really appreciate it.
Uh,
this question is for Ben.
I know we've touched on you have some played some really awesome learns
antagonists,
one that comes to mind.
So we got Daniel Rayburn from borderline.
You play Robin in place beyond the pines.
I thought it was a really great character.
Thank you.
That,
that does seem like a departure from your personality.
So can you tell us a little bit more about,
uh,
how to use that now?
Can you tell us a little bit more about your creative process to get rid of,
get ready for those characters?
Do you have any good whispers that you take from
Oh yeah,
no,
there's a lot of,
there's a lot of stealing.
I mean,
I think if you see something,
you,
you want it because what you're trying to do is bring different flavors.
You know what I mean?
I look the way I look.
I have certain things that are kind of inbuilt into me and La,
la,
la.
So you just looking for inspiration for,
you know,
this would be a bit nice in here.
This would be a bit nice in there.
So you kind of get a few ideas.
Um,
you might think about a person's mindset,
but then here's the thing about it though.
I,
I really believe you do all that stuff and you kick it around in your head.
But then game day comes,
you sort of know the story.
You know this,
you know,
you know everything that's going around.
But Game Day is just about,
you know,
frying it up,
flipping it over,
seeing what happens.
So it's really the freedom you allow yourself on game day.
And what happens is this,
it all then gets assembled like,
I would do this or do that,
do this,
do that.
Then it all gets assembled and that you take in as the character,
but there's any number of variations or ship things that I do along the way that
don't make it in or this or that or the other.
But hopefully the aggregate of all the,
the decent stuff that works in context of the film goes in and you go,
oh,
that's that character.
But it's not really that way when we're making it,
you know,
all you're doing is grabbing tiny little bits that they'll have to have their
own kind of their own funk,
their own life to them.
Not at all.
Thank you.
How many pounds on the bowser use?
Hmm?
For the,
I mean,
it varies.
I think the English Longbow was about,
was about,
or you can use those stuff fast.
So I'm asking for all for the three,
for the good of your,
I mean,
if you ask,
we have different bows for different purposes when we're filming it.
So some them are,
some
are,
some are rubberized if you're using them for fights,
uh,
to Google that,
I was trying to get them off phone
in this big room.
Oh yeah.
So what have I like to,
I mean,
I wouldn't know the actual waiting now.
It was two years ago.
I've got far more important factoids
story.
That's a fair question.
I don't know how many pounds,
fuck all that.
When I go see this,
I need to know how many pounds,
no
one a piece of popcorn will be bought till I find out how many goddamn pounds
and then his motherfucking move.
Hmm.
Go on with your questions.
This question is actually for Jeremy,
so I'm a big fan of your work.
Been around,
you know,
from gold digger.
Oh man,
thanks.
Et cetera.
He was really curious,
you know,
especially as a black actor in Hollywood,
it's really block out all that extra noise that's happening around you and to
keep finding new challenges,
new projects that are going to keep you,
you know,
when we forward,
you've got a great voice too.
We've got a great voice,
right?
Like he's on CNN or something,
but here at CNN with Jamie Foxx,
you know what man
it is.
It's just a wonderful time to be.
I've been in the game for a minute now.
It'd be actually to beat,
to be honest.
But,
uh,
it's,
it's keeping your light on.
It's like,
uh,
and what I mean by that is sometimes we'll reach certain successes and then
we'll turn our light off,
you know?
Oh,
meaning like we,
we,
we forget about why we're here.
And to me I'm always sort of looking ahead.
I feel like I'm just starting,
so when I meet these guys,
you know,
Taryn and Ben and see,
these guys had dreams and they come,
we're in the same room together and we're doing these great projects and auto.
So it's Sorta,
you know,
that keeps you going.
And it was,
as far as the noises,
sorry,
I'm not for sure.
What you,
what you meant by the,
the,
the noise.
Uh,
just like a general,
I mean,
I'm assuming that as an actor there's just always going to be some sort of
negative lifestyle.
The back after trying to find roles.
So more so you know,
for you how you just,
you know,
have like a daily mantra of,
this is what I'm going to be in the summer.
They'll go after it in order to keep moving forward.
It's,
you're so soothing is how much is,
I'm gonna just get you to record like hours.
It just your voice in it.
And that's how I'm gonna get through all this shit and just press play.
Jamie,
you can do it no matter what we do with true.
When you eat your breakfast and after you eat your breakfast,
you're going to eat your lunch and then once you eat your electric,
this is going to be,
you're great man.
Listen,
to be honest with you,
I'm,
I'm glad,
uh,
as far as being a black actor,
this is a great time for all actors.
But in a sense I've always wanted to be like,
uh,
hopefully one day we'll be able to say,
we're eating pizza.
What I mean by that is this.
And then when you eat pizza,
you don't say,
this is pizza from Italy.
Italians made it.
So therefore when it comes as far as a black actor thing,
I just want to keep on growing and keep on doing things.
So where we were,
it becomes just regular,
like,
you know,
we just doing art,
we're doing active.
And I do understand what you mean because when I do see like,
you know,
John in the,
in this movie and for the kids,
it's in New Orleans,
the road up in a bus and were yelling out,
Jamie Foxx daikon see that and have a different perspective and not feel that
there's ever any the stuff that you're talking about.
It just like how my daughter,
who's 10 years old,
she doesn't know really that having a black president was a big thing.
You know what I'm saying?
So we just keep moving and uh,
and that's all you can do.
Keep moving and stay energetic and let me get your phone number so I didn't,
I could take your voice and use that in my next film.
Great answer.
Thank you.
Question over here.
Great.
So the last quick question.
Are all the people here for Jamie?
When's,
when's her next music release?
Oh,
uh,
well me and Taryn or working on some things right now and got to it.
What was it,
Saturday night and it ain't got nobody,
but would you say again,
what would you say is
okay?
Uh,
no,
this Saturday and I,
and I gotten up by I guess money and not just,
Oh,
how I wish I had some ones too.
Oh yeah.
So that's what we doing.
Get that on Spotify.
Awesome.
It's cool.
I got a little something for you.
Oh,
let me see it.
okay.
All right.
Okay.
Thank you Beth.
Great man.
Thank you so much.
It gives you a phone.
No,
he gave me an iPod touch.
So the music on this,
right?
It's music on here.
Oh,
you did great.
I like that.
I love the day we go to,
what's your name?
Elbert.
That's perfect.
I knew it was going to be some high shit on him.
Eh?
Did he make it happen?
They didn't have and I love it.
Okay.
All right.
That guy,
we've got a couple of minutes left.
One minute left here.
What's next for you?
Uh,
Taryn.
What's going on?
Okay.
Um,
uh,
I'm going to spend the next,
we're going off spreading the word about spreading the word about Robin Hood,
which comes out on the 26th of November.
And I'm very excited about it.
And then I'm going to go and put my feet up for a little while because I've had
a busy summer and I am knackered.
So,
uh,
I'm gonna enjoy Christmas to be with my family and not,
um,
work for a little while.
I think I want to talk about rocket man.
Oh yes,
I have that.
Yes.
Okay.
I see what I see.
I see what you're doing.
Oh,
you gave me,
that was good.
That was good as,
yeah.
Uh,
My next movie,
I'm playing out in John in a musical about his life.
So that comes out in,
um,
that comes out in May,
and scraped,
you know,
the joy of,
of my job is that there's variety.
And as Ben,
you know,
Ben talks about different flavors.
It's,
um,
a very,
very different sides of my personality and I feel it stretched me in,
in ways I haven't been stretched before.
And,
um,
I've loved the,
actually,
I've really loved it and I'm very excited about the film.
I have high hopes for it.
Yeah,
me too.
That's all.
I want more singing.
Lots of shouting,
lots of kissing men.
Um,
it's been awesome.
I've loved it.
It's been such a great opportunity.
Ben,
you're going to be in captain marvel.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So cool.
Yeah.
I'm scrawling I am scrolling.
It's just going to complete,
uh,
this,
you know,
this iteration of evil and let me tell you something.
When I'll be scrolling,
you watch out,
I'm going to them up and that'll come out in March and you can all get you a
little dose of flavor or back on your tongue.
Around that time.
He got to be green.
It's going to shape shift is going to be very nasty.
Dade scrawl,
them
auto,
you're filming a TV show called his dark materials,
um,
about two children who embark on a magical adventure through a parallel universe
I didn't cover.
That's correct.
Right.
You're looking at me like you're confused.
Yeah,
no,
it's okay.
That'll do.
That'll do it.
So I,
I didn't,
I didn't cover it first that you also directed the very first Black Mirror
episode on Netflix.
[inaudible]
do you have a,
um,
kind of,
uh,
an attraction to the alternate universe sort of thing here?
Uh,
no,
not at all.
Have an attraction to telling stories that,
um,
just ask a few questions.
And so when the prime minister is also do something with an animal,
that's an interesting reflection on politics.
And Jamie,
what's next for you?
Um,
just,
um,
I just finished this movie with Michael B.
Jordan called just mercy of you get a chance.
Check out Google.
Brian Stevenson and Walter McMillan about a man who's wrongly accused of a
murder,
uh,
in Alabama and he's gay.
He gets put on death row without a trial.
He's on death row for six years in a young Brian Stevenson play by Michael B.
Jordan,
who's an intern comes and takes his case and a wonderful things happen.
Um,
and then,
uh,
um,
I'm going back out on my standup tour,
so make sure y'all come check out my,
I got brand new jokes,
man.
Is I got,
I got,
I got some,
some
Jordan's that you really got to enjoy it and it,
and it's going to be great navigating through the new time of doing standup
comedians.
So right now the title is called killed the comedian.
So make sure you come check me out.
Nice.
Nice man.
[inaudible] Robin Hood in theaters November 21st
or second visit Robin hood.movie for more information,
everyone please give me help me give them one more round.
Thank you.
Thanks.